وتشهد منطقه طلال كفر شوبا الحدوديه جنوبي
لبنان انتشارا لقوات الطوارئ الدوليه
اليونيفيل للفصل بين عناصر الجيش اللبناني
والقوات الاسرائيليه ياتي ذلك بعد القاء
القوات الاسرائيليه قنابل مسيله للدموع
على مواطنين لبنانيين تجمعوا للاحتجاج على
تجريف اراضي زراعيه في المنطقه وقال الجيش
اللبناني ان قوته نفذت انتشارا في كفر
شوبا بمواجهه القوات الاسرائيليه بينما
قالت اليونيفيل ان عناصرها انتشر في
المنطقه لضمان استمرار وقف الاعمال
العدائيه وتخفيف حده التوتر وحثت
اليونيفيل جميع الاطراف على ضبط النفس
واستخدام اليات التنسيق للحفاظ على
الاستقرار في المتابعه معنا من بيروت
مراسل الجزيره جونيطانيوس كما ينضم الينا
من القدس مراسل الجزيره الياس كرم ابدا
معك جوني كيف يبدو الوضع ميدانيا معاد
الانتشار للجيش اللبناني وقوه اليونيفيلد
في الواقع سهام ساعتين الماضيتين لم تشهد
اي مستجدات بشكل كبير ذلك ان الهدوء الحذر
ما يزال سيد الموقف في منطقه تلال كفر
شوبا وتحديدا في محيط خط الانسحاب في ظل
استنفار المتبادل بين الجيشين اللبناني
والاسرائيلي وايضا الحضور الكثيف لقوات
الطوارئ الدوليه من اجل اعاده الامور الى
هدوءها الطبيعي وكانت قوات الطوارئ
الدوليه دعت الى العوده الى اليات التنسيق
المتبعه وضبط النفس وقالت ان عناصرها
كانوا موجودين في المكان منذ وقت باكر من
اجل متابعه الامور ميدانيا قرابه العاشره
من صباح هذا اليوم تقريبا بتوقيت بيروت
تجمع عدد من اهالي منطقه كفر شوبا قربه
خطا الانسحاب في تلك الملتقى من اجل
الاحتجاج على اعمال التجريف التي يقوم بها
الجانب الاسرائيلي منذ ايام قام هؤلاء
بالاحتجاج في تلك المنطقه فردت عليهم
القوات الاسرائيليه بالقاء القنابل
المسيله للدم يعتبر هؤلاء الاهالي وهم من
المزارعين والرعاه ان هذه الاراضي تلال
كفرشوبا وما زارع شبعه وطبعا لبنان الرسمي
يعتبر ان هذه الاراضي هي اراضي محتله
انسحب الجيش الاسرائيلي من جنوب لبنان عام
2000 لكنه ابقى على احتلاله لهاتين
المنطقتين وهما منطقتين لبنانيتين بامتياز
بحسب الراي الرسمي وبحسب اهالي تلك
المناطق حتى ان بعض الاهالي يبرزون وثائق
تؤكد ملكيتهم لهذه الاراضي وبالتالي هم
يعتبرون ان اي اعمال يقوم بها الجانب
الاسرائيلي في تلك المنطقه هي تغير من
معالم الطبيعه الجغرافيه ومن شانها ان
تضيع بعض الملكيات وعليها كانوا يحتجوا في
الايام القليله الماضيه واليوم تجمعوا في
تلك المنطقه من اجل الاحتجاج مره جديده
وحصل ما حصل الجيش اللبناني اعلن عبر موقع
تويتر انه نفذ انتشارا
بمواجهه انتشار الجيش الاسرائيلي وقوه
الطوارئ الدوليه طبعا تتابع الموضوع لبنان
طبعا يتحفظ على خط الانسحاب هذا هو خط
موضع نزاع اكثر من مره ينتقل المزارعون
اللبنانيون والرعاه اللبنانيون الى الجانب
الاخر من خط الانسحاب من اجل القيام
باعمالهم هذه المنطقه غالبا ما تشهد
توترات بين الاهالي اللبنانيين وبين الجيش
الاسرائيلي بسبب طبيعه المنطقه والخلاف
والنزاع على ملكيه الاراضي هناك عاده تقوم
القوات الاسرائيليه بخطف بعض الماشيه ومن
ثم تعيدها مثلا بعد تدخل قوات الطوارئ
الدوليه ولكن المشهد تصاعد اليوم بعد حال
التوتر التي خرجت في الايام القليله
الماضيه بالامس كانت قوات الطوارئ الدوليه
وقائد قوات الطوارئ الدوليه عقد الاجتماع
الدوري من اجل متابعه الاوضاع عند الخط
الازرق مع الجانب اللبناني والضباط من
الجيش اللبناني والجانب الاسرائيلي وكان
ايضا دعا الى ضبط الاوضاع والعوده الى
الهدوء عند المنطقه الحدوديه ومتابعه
الملف من خلال ق طوارئ الدوليه الان
الامور عدت الى هدوءها بشكل او باخر مع
استمرار هذا الاستنفار طبعا الجيش
اللبناني يتابع القضيه وقد يكون له بيان
يتحدث فيه عن ما جرى وعن مجريات ما يعتبره
لبنان الخرق الاسرائيلي وايضا قوات
الطوارئ الدوليه تتابع هذه القضيه من اجل
تاكد عوده الهدوء الى المنطقه وفض هذا
التوتر وهذا الاشتباك الذي حصل بين
الاهالي من جهه وبين الجيش الاسرائيلي من
جهه اخرى ابقى